more than 50 years away from home
Senegalese soldiers that fought Wars for
France in the 20th century are returning
to their Homeland after the French
government agreed to give them the right
to full pension in Senegal I am
Overjoyed to see my children my
grandchildren and my great-grandchildren
I am home finally
almost a quarter of a million Africans
fought for France they were known as the
tirayo Senegalese 85 year old insale say
was one of them while he was awarded a
medal for his service the French State
gave him a fraction of his pension 40
years after retirement a bitter
Injustice say he says
I have mixed feelings about my
experience Freedom equality and
fraternity the French motto was for us
only a symbol it wasn't there in
practice we were humiliated because of
the color of our skin
between the train station and the port
is this statue known as Demba and Dupont
representing a white and a black Soldier
arm in Army here hundreds of thousands
of Africans left on ships to fight a war
far from home it's more than a symbol
but a tribute to black Africans that
lost their lives to free Europeans and
many believe that this is a chapter of
History too often overlooked historians
believe the tirayers were instrumental
in liberating southern France during
World War II but were stopped from
entering Paris commanders replaced them
with white soldiers
the role of the African man in history
has always been minimized I think it's
unfair that France failed to recognize
the contribution of Africans when France
was on its knees and humiliated
many veterans died without getting the
recognition and compensation for their
contribution with a growing anti-french
sentiment in former French African
colonies for say the return of War
veterans is a victory for all of those
Africans that lost their lives for
France Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar